because it all depends on how you do a
trauma
and uh trauma
uh for me and that that's that's all
other lecture but trauma is not what
happens to you
it's what happens inside you
as a result of what happens to you
and things can happen inside you for
which you don't need very dramatic
events
but trauma essentially is a restriction
of your capacity
it's a limitation it's a constriction in
the body it's a constriction in your
mental capacity to respond in the
present moment from your authentic self
essentially trauma is a restriction of
your authentic self in the present
moment that's what trauma is
for which you don't need dramatic events
so
what were these characteristics that i
noticed in people with
illness i'll illustrate them by means of
newspaper clippings from the globe and
mail
the first one is an article written in
the first person by a woman who's
diagnosed with breast cancer her name is
donna
and her husband's name is high
and harold is the doctor and heist's
first wife died of breast cancer
now donna the second wife is diagnosed
with the same condition
and you might think what an unfortunate
coincidence
well unfortunately it may be coincidence
is not
this guy for a particular reason mary is
a certain type of woman
it's that simple
what type of woman
well here's donna's description of her
diagnosis
harold tells me that the lump is small
and most assuredly not in my lymph nodes
unlike that of heist's first wife whose
cancer has spread everywhere by the time
i found it
you're not going to die you reassures me
but i'm worried about high i say
i won't have the strength to support him
now
your psychotherapist
noticed anything
so this
she's the one that's potentially facing
surgery radiation maybe chemotherapy and
what is her first and automatic thought
how will i look to look after his needs
this would be so tough on him
he's already lost the wife to breast
cancer so this automatic and compulsive
regard
for the emotional needs of others while
ignoring your own
is a major risk factor for illness
for reasons i will explain
the others are obituaries also from the
gold medal from the lies lived column
and obituaries are fascinating because
uh
they tell us so much not just about the
people who died but also about what we
as a society value
and often and in every single case what
i'm going to read you is presented as a
positive thing
as a good thing
which is why
the expression the good die young
they often do
for
for for reasons that should be clear to
you by the end of this conversation
and these are the people
for whose funerals
untimely deaths and funerals hundreds of
people show up
[Music]
mourning this wonderful person
so this man was a physician here in
toronto he died age 55 of cancer and the
obituary said never for a day did he
contemplate giving up the work he so
loved at toronto sick children's
hospital
he carried on with his duties throughout
his year-long battle with cancer
stopping only a few days before he died
so
consider the scenario where a friend of
yours is diagnosed with malignancy
would you turn to them and say hey buddy
here's how you deal with it go back to
work tomorrow
and all the while you're undergoing
treatment
never consider your life never take a
moment to
see what's stressing you
never
be alone and to deal with the reality of
it just work every day until you drop
so this rigid and compulsive
identification with duty
role and responsibility
rather than the authentic self
is a major risk factor for illness
as a matter of fact
any identification with anything outside
of yourself
is a risk factor of illness
the next to be cherry uh was written by
a grateful husband
who's died whose wife died of breast
cancer at age 55
and this spouse writes
in her entire life she never got into a
fight with anyone
the worst you could say was foolie or
something else along those lines
she had no ego she just blended in with
the environment in an unassuming manner
now
i'm i'm married to my wife ray for 49
years almost now
and many times i wish that she would
blend in with the environment
in an unassuming manner
as i'm sure you have if you have a
spouse or a partner
but
if you're fortunate
they didn't do that
they didn't do that because what's being
described here of course is the
repression of anger
the repression of healthy anger
and the repression of healthy anger
actually disarms the immune system
physiologically it does when you repress
anger healthy anger you're actually
um undercutting the activity of certain
immune cells this has been shown in the
laboratory
i said healthy anger
and so we have to make a distinction
between healthy anger and unhealthy
anger and i won't do that now but
but be sure to remind me if i haven't
made that distinction clear
by the end
unhealthy anger is rage
and in the afternoon of the rage episode
your risk of a stroke or a heart attack
double for the next two hours according
to israeli and american studies why
because of course in a rage episode you
got um
real adrenaline discharge which narrows
your blood vessels increases your blood
pressure
can make the heart rate irregular and
even clots the blood
so i'm talking about that's not healthy
either so we have a problem here if we
repress healthy anger we get sick and if
we and if we give in to unhealthy anger
we also get sick
so that's the third characteristic is
the repression of healthy anger and the
last one and the fourth one
is
illustrated in an obituary that you'll
have to believe i didn't make up it is
from the global mail
and this is from a physician about a
physician in ottawa who died also of
cancer at age 72
and it said here sydney and his mother
had an incredibly special relationship a
bond that was apparent in all aspects of
their lives until her death
as a married man with young children
sydney made a point to have dinner with
his parents every day as his wife roslyn
and their four kids waited for him at
home
he would walk in greeted by yet another
dinner to eat and to enjoy
never wanted to disappoint either woman
in his life sydney kept having two
dinners a day for years
until gradual weight gain began to raise
suspicions
okay and this is printed as a beautiful
thing
now this man suffered from from two
fatal beliefs and when i say fatal i
mean literally fatal
if you got these beliefs
drop them today if you can if you can't
drop them
find out why
one is that you're responsible for other
people feel
nobody's ever responsible if anybody
else feels unless you're a parent
then you are
and secondly that you must not
disappoint anybody
so then those are the characteristics
um there's automatic concern
and regard for the emotional needs of
others while ignoring your own
rigid and compulsive identification with
duty role and responsibility rather than
the authentic self or the needs of the
self
repression of anger
and
the beliefs that you're responsible for
how people feel and that you must never
disappoint anyone
[Music]
you